prime minister contemplating the scale
of the challenge stopping illegal Boat
Crossings across this stretch of water
his priority is very high legal and
illegal migration levels hitting record
highs given this PM a very real
political problem that he's promised to
fix I'd like to update you on the
progress that the Home Secretary and I
are making
and my message is this our plan is
starting to work I will not rest until
the boats are stopped with grip and
determination the government can fix
this in Dover to highlight small signs
of delivery illegal Crossings down a
fifth on this time last year new sites
to move migrants out of hotels and today
recommitting to clearing a backlog of
nearly a hundred thousand Asylum claims
I promise to clear through the backlog
of people waiting for initial decision
numbers published Today Show that the
initial decision Legacy backlog is down
by over seventeen thousand
and we're on track to clear it entirely
by the end of the year
for people here it's a problem causing
concern and one they want fixed do you
think anyone can stop the small boats no
is the honest answer I don't think at
the moment it's going anywhere I think
it's a bit of stalemate
um and I don't think whoever is in power
is and if they put it in their top five
priorities and had a time scale on it
will ever get it sorted within that time
scale it's going to keep going on and
it's going to keep going on we're
becoming strangers in our own Community
not many use public transport but
certainly in the roads and around the
supermarkets you begin to think well you
know this was a
Pleasant quiet community and then
suddenly it's uh it's changed beyond
recognition I don't know whether they've
had much success with it at the moment
but uh
don't sound very confident they're going
to sort it no I don't I don't sound
confident at all
there's huge skepticism from even Rishi
sunak's biggest backers that the Prime
Minister can really stop the boats the
scale of the problem is simply enormous
a record 45
000 people made the Crossing in small
boats last year alone and the solutions
are fiendishly complicated so the pledge
might be to stop the boats but
realistically all the prime minister can
really hope to do is reduce the numbers
in time for the next general election
back in Westminster laws being pushed
through to give the government new
powers to detain and Deport people but
still questions from conservative
backbenchers about progress with the
policy sharing rooms and barges and
drones and relying on the French is not
the answer I think we all know anybody
in a common sense in this place know
what the answer is enough to get the
flights off to Orlando as quick as
possible so please advise me and the
great people of Ashford when these
flights will go ahead
from the shoreline of France the Final
Destination just visible and as the
weather heats up so will the number of
Crossings stop the boats such a simple
slogan yet so hard to deliver and time
is not on this prime minister's side
Beth Rigby Sky News in Dover